COMMITTEE HEARING FOR AUGUST
ELEVENTH. TWENTY TWENTY. WE
YEAR. WE HAVE A QUORUM FOLKS
YOU'RE ENTERING THE CHAMBER NOW.
MR DARDEN- IS ON HIS WAY. HE'S
ONE OF THE PRESENTERS AND THEN
MISTER HILL SENATOR HILL IS THE
OTHER PERSON OR- ALL READ THE-
BUT THE NECESSARY LANGUAGE TO
THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MASKS BE
WORN IN PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. MISTER
RAKISH DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO FORMALLY
CALLED A QUORUM. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
DALY HERE DALY HERE MAYES MAYES
PRESENT BERMAN IN HERE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW PRESENT CALDERON GEN
GEN HERE COOLEY COOPER COOPER
PRESENT FRAZIER GIPSON GIPSON
HERE GRAYSON GRAYSON HERE COM
LONGER. VOEPEL YO- WOULD. HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM. HE JUST WOKE
US UP RANDY. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM WHERE THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING. TODAY FOR
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
THE SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC. NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOUR IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS. WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND IN
OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH ANY THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
POLICE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING. HIS
OR HER BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE
LINE IT WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU WERE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
SIX. AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THE AT&T
MODERATOR WILLIAM ONLY RESPOND
WHEN THE CHAIR SPEAKS TO. THE
MODERATOR SO PLEASE PROMPT THEM
DIRECTLY SO THEY CAN QUEUE UP
COLLARS AND OPEN OR CLOSE THE
PHONE LINE. PLEASE BE SURE TO
PROVIDE THE CHAIR WITH THE LIST
OF WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE
APPROVED. AS I SAID THE PHONE
MODERATOR WILL NOT RESPOND
UNLESS THE CHAIR ADDRESSES THEM
DIRECTLY. ALL RIGHTS LET'S
PROCEED WITH A FOUR BILLS
MISTER DOTS HERE WELCOME MISTER
DODD LET'S VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IF. THE MOTION SECOND
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES MAYES
AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
HI CALDERON CHEN CHEN HI COOLEY
COOPER COOPER ALL RIGHT FRAZIER
GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I KAMLAGER VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD HI. THAT'S TEN
BOOKS ALRIGHT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PASSES GO NOW TO MR
DODD'S BILL SENATOR DODD'S BILL
SB EIGHT SEVEN TWO SENATOR IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK.
BACK WHERE YOU BELONG. YOU KNOW
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOOD TO SEE YOU TO I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR GREAT
WORK ON THIS BILL HELPING TO
CRAFT SOME A VERY IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS. I YEAR ROUND FIRE
SEASONS OF THE DEVASTATING
FIRES IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATIONS. TO INCREASE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS REGARDING
PROPERTY INSURANCE. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL. PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS IT PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF INSURED LOSSES
AFTER DECLARED DISASTERS IN
SEVERAL IMPORTANT WAYS. FIGHTS
A SIXTY DAY GRACE PERIOD FOR
PREMIUM PAYMENT. REQUIRES
ADVANCE OF FOUR MONTHS OF A. L.
E. IF THE CLAIM IS RELATED TO A
DECLARED EMERGENCY. ALLOWS
EIGHTY ELLIE WHEN THE HOME IS
RENDERED UNINHABITABLE AS A
RESULT OF A COVERED PERIL. IN
PROHIBITS A DEDUCTION OF LAND
VALUE IF THE POLICY HOLDER
PURCHASE A REPLACEMENT HOME. AT
ANOTHER LOCATION. PROVIDING
THESE ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATIONS
OF PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS
WILL ROVIDE ADDITIONAL RELIEF
AND SAFEGUARDS TO INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES. ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MICHAEL
MARTINEZ FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. GO
AHEAD MISTER MARTINEZ. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
SHARE DALY VICE CHAIR MAYES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
COMMISSIONER LOT AS THE SPONSOR
OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR DODD FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. WE'RE GOING HOME OR
BEING UNABLE TO RESIDE IN ONE'S
HOME FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME AND IS AN- UNIMAGINABLY
PAINFUL EXPERIENCE THAT TAKES
AN EMOTIONAL TOLL. ON PEOPLE IN
FAMILIES WHICH IS WHY
COMMISSIONER A LOT OF FEEL SO
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS BILL. SB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO CREATES FAIR
AND REASONABLE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND PROVIDES
CLARIFICATION NEEDED TO HELP
EASE THE BURDEN FOR HOMEOWNERS.
AND RENTERS AS THEY REBUILD
THEIR HOMES AND LIVES AFTER
MAJOR CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
SENATOR DODD PROVIDED AN
EXCELLENT OVERVIEW THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS WHICH ARE ALL
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS THAT WILL HELP THEM
DURING CHALLENGING TIMES. OF
REBUILDING THEIR HOME AND THEIR
LIVES. AFTER A CATASTROPHIC
DISASTER. WE APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS INTERESTED IN
FINDING A SOLUTION WITH THIS
MEASURE IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AS THIS BILL
HAS MOVED FORWARD INTO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AGAIN WE RE
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE AND
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I DO
HAVE MY COLLEAGUES TWENTY
SECURELY DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
FOR CONSUMER SERVICES MARKET
CONTACT HERE WITH ME. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MISTER MARTINEZ. SENATOR DO
YOU HAVE OTHER OTHER FOLKS-
THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF WHO ARE
PREPARED TO. NO WE CAN JUST
PROCEED TO MISCARRIAGE THANK
YOU. ARE THERE OTHER FOLKS
SILVA. ONLINE READY TO SPEAK.
TO THE A. T. AND T. MODERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN Q. YES
AND THAT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE WIND FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
STACEY HEATING RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT TO
A PERSON ON THE PHONE. WE GOT A
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN THAT IS
LINE ONE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WILL BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
HERE FOR NEXT PERSON ON THE
PHONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT LINE THREE
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ANNA BUCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ELEVEN THAT
FLYING ONE ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MARK DOMINANTE HALF
OF UNITED POLICY HOLDERS IN
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. E. E. SEVEN
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IF NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT- ARE THERE ANY PERSONS
HERE IN THE- IN THE BUILDING.
IN ONE OF THE. LOCATIONS HERE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS
BILL. ANY PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL IF NOT
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT YOU HAVE. AGAIN HE'S A
GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE IN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF B. SEVEN TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN%
OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT SEVEN
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
BE JUST ONE MOMENT THANK YOU.
AB ONE NUMBER THIRTY THREE
THAT'S LINE THREE THREE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING NUMBER
SEVEN TAYLOR WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION. I WILL
WALK WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
FIRST I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE AND
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR WORK
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. WE CAN
CHANGES ARE VERY BENEFICIAL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED. WE ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
COSTS RELATED TO THE EXPANSION
OF ADDITIONAL LIVING EXPENSE OR
A ONLY COVERAGE TO ON DAMAGE
HOMES. THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION THIS YEAR ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. AND INSURERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT SHARPLY DISAGREE
ABOUT THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL. AND WE HOPE IN THE
FUTURE THE DEPARTMENT WILL
PROVIDE A DETAILED COST
ANALYSIS TO THE COMMITTEE. THAT
EXPLAIN HOW LEGISLATION THEY
SUPPORT WILL AFFECT CONSUMERS
AND INSURERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF F.
B. EIGHT SEVEN QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU. THINK THAT CONCLUDES THE
TESTIMONY SENATOR DODD.
COMMITTEE STAFF MENTIONED TO ME
THAT THERE'S A TECHNICAL. ITEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
WITH IT'S A CROSS REFERENCE ARE
YOU AWARE OF THIS YOUR YOUR
STAFF AND MENTIONED IT TO MR
WRECKAGE. I YES I AM SO YOU'RE-
YEAH WHATEVER AT A MEMBER
TECHNICAL MA'AM IT IS I. B.
SUPPORT MR WRECKAGE WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN TO MAKE THIS ALL A
COPA STATIC I BELIEVE THE
SENATOR JUST DID IT GOOD. JUST
TO JUST SIMPLY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD- ANY ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVING QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL.
MISTER WOOD HAS IS MIKE UP YEAH.
THANK THANK YOU CENTER DR BRING
THIS BILL I THINK YOU AND I
BOTH WORKED ON A LOT OF ISSUES
RELATED TO INSURANCE AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE A BILL IN THE
HOUSE IN THE IN YOUR HOUSE ON
THIS- THIS IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY I THINK OF THIS AS
EVEN A BIGGER POSSIBILITY IN
THE TOWN OF PARADISE- WHERE
HOMES ARE BEING REBUILT YET
THEY DON'T HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE AND
I CAN'T IMAGINE. A CITIES AND-
ACTUALLY ISSUING OCCUPANCY
PERMITS WHEN SOMEONE CAN'T GET
WATER OR OR THINGS LIKE THAT'S
POSSIBLE BUT BUT IT COULDN'T IN
MY HOMETOWN OF SANTA ROSA WE
HAD AN AREA WHERE- WE HAD A WE
HAD A HUGE CHALLENGE WITH A
WATER SYSTEM AND THAT THAT THAT
TROUBLES ME AND SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO HELP ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING GETTING BACK
INTO THEIR HOMES. I LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE I HAVE
SEVERAL NEIGHBORS THEY'RE STILL
LIVING IN TRAILERS MOTOR HOMES-
WAITING TO BE ABLE TO REBUILD
IT WE ARE ALMOST THREE YEARS
AWAY A SENSE THAT SINCE THE
FIRES OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SO CLEARLY WE'VE GOT CHALLENGES
WITH THESE THE LIVING EXPENSE.
IN IN IN IN SOME OF OUR
POLICIES BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH
OF TIME IS REQUIRING TO BUILD
HOUSES WE WERE NOT IN A
POSITION WE WERE NOT I DON'T
BELIEVE INSURANCE WAS DESIGNED
FOR THE CATASTROPHIC LOSS OF
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS IT WAS
DESIGNED FOR THE LOSS OF A
SINGLE HOME- WHEN YOU LOSE
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS AND LUCY
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THESE CREATE
HUGE CHALLENGES SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING TO GO FORWARD AND
I'M A VERY HAPPY SUPPORT IT
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AN APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
WOULD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. IF NOT
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND SO
LET'S DO THE ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES
MAYES AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE CHAN JAN HI COOLEY.
COOPER COOPER HI FRAZIER GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON. GRAYSON I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD WOULD I.
THIRTEEN ZERO. YOU SAY THIRTEEN
ZERO I THINK OKAY. HER WITH TWO
MISSING MEMBERS TWELVE SO
TWELVE ZERO. BERMAN AMENDED
THANK YOU SENATOR GREAT BILL
THE JOB. THE LAST BILL IS- SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
HILL HE IS- INVOLVED WITH THE
COMMITTEE PROCEEDING OVER IN
THE SENATE. AND WE'VE ANY
INDICATION MR WRECKAGE THE-
STATISTA MISTER HILL. I AM NOT
NOT PRECISE I'M TRYING FROM HIS
STAFF COULD SOMEBODY CHECK WITH
HIS STAFF PLEASE. AND BY THE
WAY WE- REGARDING SENATOR HILLS
BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE THERE IS
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE. THAT I
THINK IT'S BEING CIRCULATED NOW
IF I THINK SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAD IT IN
SOME. DID NOT. SO IT'S MY
INTENTION TO RECOMMEND THAT
AMENDMENT SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAD.
WHILE WAITING FOR SENATOR HILL
WHY DON'T WE GIVE FOLKS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MISTER RECORD
YOU WANT TO CALL THE ROLL FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
ADD ONS THAT ABSENTEES ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALDERON.
CALDERON HI COOLEY FRAZIER
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER II
. TWELVE
ZERO. MARKER WE HEARING
ANYTHING FROM CENTER HILL STAFF.
I'M SORRY MR DALY. ARE WE
HEARINGS HE'S HE'S WALKING OVER
AS WE SPEAK OKAY OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL THERE IS. CENTER HELLO
WELCOME YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE THIS MORNING WITH SO
MUCH GOING ON. THANK YOU.
SHOULD I PROCEED YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD CENTER THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE A BILL THAT.
SEEKS TO PROVIDE NECESSARY
MEDICAL CARE FOR OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS FIGHTING COVERT
NINETEEN. FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
DISCUSSED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
STRIKE THE FIVE AND 5%
LANGUAGE. AND REPLACE THIS
LANGUAGE WITH A PLACEHOLDER TO
GIVE US MORE TIME TO WORK ON
OUTBREAK OF LANGUAGE. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF. ACTUALLY YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO YOU AND IN
OUR COLLECTION. COLLABORATION
ON THIS THIS LEGISLATION- AND
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH ME
AND- OUR STAFF ON THESE ISSUES
UNDER THIS TIGHT SCHEDULE. FOR
THE SAKE OF BREVITY OUT I WILL
NOT BEGIN WITH A LONG
DISCUSSION OF COVERT NINETEEN.
WE'VE ALL LIVED IT AND ARE
CONTINUING TO LIVE IT. SINCE
MARCH MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND AMERICANS HAVE
DIED OF OVER NINETEEN THAT'S
NEARLY THREE TIMES THE AMERICAN
CASUALTIES OF WAR OF THE
VIETNAM WAR. AND GREATER THAN
ALL OF THE AMERICAN CASUALTIES
DURING THE FIRST WORLD WAR
WHILE MUCH MEDIA ATTENTION HAS
BEEN ON THE ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
OF THIS. PANDEMIC THE SCALE OF
HUMAN. IS UNPRECEDENTED IT
DIFFICULT TO OVERSTATE. AND
THAT'S WHY MISTER CHAIR I AM SO
GLAD THAT WE CAME TOGETHER TO
CO AUTHOR SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE.
THIS BILL EXTENDS A COVERT
NINETEEN REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. TO BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR WORKERS. BUT IT
DOES SO CAREFULLY TO BALANCE
THE NEEDS OF WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA. SIMPLY
PUT THE BILL DOES THREE THINGS.
FIRST SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
CODIFIES THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER COVERING ALL
ESSENTIAL WORKERS A JULY FOURTH.
SECOND THIS BILL EXTENDS A
PRESUMPTION TO FRONTLINE
WORKERS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
INFECTIONS AFTER JULY FOURTH.
THIS INCLUDES PEACE OFFICERS
FIREFIGHTERS EMTS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. FINALLY SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE EXTENDS A
PRESUMPTION TO WORKERS IN THE
EVENT OF A COVERT NINETEEN
OUTBREAK AT A WORK SITE. THIS
IS YOUR IS THE WORKERS WHO ARE
AT A HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. ARE COVERED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTION WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE WORK PLACES THAT
DID NOT HAVE APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MASK POLICIES.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
FINALIZE THIS LANGUAGE AND
PROTECT AS MANY VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE.
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY ADDRESSES THE
OCCUPATIONAL TOLD THE PANDEMIC.
AND MAKES CALIFORNIA'S
WORKPLACES SAFER. THEREFORE
NOTING THE URGENCY OF THE
MOMENT I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY NINE.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND TO.
TO PASS THE BILL ONE HIGHLIGHT
WHAT SENATOR HILL SAID- HE'S
PROPOSING TO DELETE THE
LANGUAGE THAT DEALS WITH THE
FIVE AND FIVE RULE AND THEN
HE'S- ASKING FOR THE AMENDMENT
THAT WITH THE SO CALLED INTENT
LANGUAGE- AND WILL EXPECT MORE
DETAIL AT SOME POINT. BEFORE
THE END OF THE SESSION ON THAT
THEY'RE STILL DISCUSSIONS GOING
ON- AND SO FORTH- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT ABOUT THE BILL
AT THIS POINT BEFORE WE IVITE
TESTIMONY. MISTER MAYES. YES I
DID I CAN I GOT A LETTER FROM
THE- FROM THE FIREFIGHTERS-%
YESTERDAY- THAT THEY BROUGHT UP
SOME GOOD POINTS AND SINCE- THE
AUTHOR HAD SAID THAT THIS WAS A
WORK IN PROGRESS. THE ONE THING
I WOULD LIKE TO THE TO BE ABLE
TO POINT OUT ARE SOME OF THE
THEIR ITEMS ONE OF THEM- IS TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE RETROACTIVE TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY. A TO
EXTEND PROTECTION BEYOND
SEPARATION OR TERMINATION AT
THE PROTECT PROTECTION OF
PERSONALLY FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE ORDERED TO QUARANTINE.
IS ACTUALLY SEVERAL OTHER ITEMS
ON HERE WITHOUT GOING THROUGH
ALL OF THE MEASURE YOUR YOU'LL
HAVE THE LETTER BUT THEY
ACTUALLY MAKE AN AWFUL LOT OF
SENSE TO ME AND SINCE THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS WE'VE GOT
SOME. LANGUAGE TO AMEND TODAY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
LOOK- AT THE AT THEIR BY
PROPOSALS AS WELL. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS TO MR CHAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE- I WANTED A
CLARIFICATION TERMS OF SOME
EVENTS THAT WILL BE- BROUGHT TO
THE TABLE BY APPRECIATE SENATOR
HILL FOR BRING THIS. BILL TO
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE BUT IN
THE EVENT AND EMPLOYEES IS
EXPOSED SO THEIR COVERT POP UP
AUTHORED EMPLOYEES AS REQUIRED
FOR QUARANTINE UNDER THIS BILL
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS-
WANT UNDERSTAND IF THE EMPLOYER
WOULD RECEIVING ADDITIONAL PAID
LEAVE. FOR THE RECOMMEND
FOURTEEN DAY QUARANTINE OR
WOULD IT BE EMPLOYEE HAVE TO BE
USING THEIR ACCRUED SICK TIME.
WHAT. JIM WHAT WAS THE QUESTION
OF THAT HAPPENING IS THEY'RE
SICKLY SICK TIME IS THAT WOULD
BE A QUESTION WAS. YES OKAY
VIA- THE- YEAH WE'RE GOING TO
REIMBURSE FOR SICK LEAVE- IF-
FOR THOSE WHO MUCH QUARANTINE
SO THEY YET I MEAN THAT'S-
THAT'S A COMMONSENSE CHANGE
THAT- WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
HAMMER OUT THE DETAILS. WITH
THE LABOR AND THE EMPLOYERS AT
THIS POINT BUT THAT WITH THEIR
QUARANTINE THEY SHOULD BE.
COMPENSATED AND REIMBURSED FOR
THAT TIME. AND THAT'S THE GOAL
AND WE JUST NEED TO GET THE
FINE TUNING OF THAT TO PUT IT
TOGETHER. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION VERY APPROPRIATE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR FOR-
FOR CLARIFYING THAT MISTER
GIBSON HAS A QUESTION. BURKE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS MORE OF
A STATE I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WE BELIEVE THAT IS
PRETTY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS
ALREADY- TO GET THE GOVERNOR
PUTTING FORTH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO SPEAK TO THIS AND
THANK THE SENATOR FOR PICKING
THIS UP BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
THOSE. INDIVIDUALS EMPLOYEES
SHOULD BE PROTECTED- IN THIS
MATTER AND HAPPY THAT HE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS IT
SEEMS ABSOLUTELY REASONABLE I
SAW THIS PRIOR AND AGAIN IT'S
ONE BIG THREE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR GIBSON.
MISCON LONGER. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS- REALLY IMPORTANT BILL I
HAVE ALSO BEEN RECEIVING
LETTERS AND TAKING CALLS FROM
ADVOCATES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE- AND WANTED I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU COULD-
ADDRESS. HOW LONG TERM EFFECTS
OF. IT WOULD BE ADDRESS- IN
THIS BILL THAT'S BEEN A CONCERN.
WELL AS SOME CONCERNS AROUND.
THE NOTION OF MULTIPLE WORKERS
FILING CLAIMS- AND SORT OF
CROSS CLEAN AND IF THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED IN THE AMENDMENTS OR
AND OR IF THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU ALL ARE WORKING TOWARDS IN
YOUR CONTINUED NEGOTIATIONS
WHICH I'VE HEARD HAVE BEEN VERY
ROBUST AND SO I WANT TO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
TRYING TO FIND THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE TWO AND THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS AND- THOSE
ARE THE EXACT QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP AND
WORK THROUGH TO GET THE ANSWERS
FOR ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF HOW
LONG- SHOULD THERE BE A SUNSET
AT SOME POINT IN TIME THE WILL
THERE BE A VACCINE THAT PREACH
THE CURE WE DON'T KNOW BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WITHOUT
THAT THAT THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ESTABLISH THE PARAMETERS THAT.
SPECIFICALLY PROTECT THE
WORKERS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON AS WE GO FORWARD SO
WE WILL HAVE THE LANGUAGE ONE
THREE IN THE NEXT OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE WE'RE- TWO WEEK TIME
FRAME. AND WE WILL HAVE IT
BEFORE IT COME EITHER THROUGH
FREE BEFORE THE OR YOU WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT AND
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL BE SATISFIED
WITH THAT THANK YOU RICHARD.
GOOD THAT'S COLOR FOR. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO COMMENT AT THIS
POINT BEFORE WE OPEN UP TO THE
PUBLIC FOR TESTIMONY. WE DO
HAVE A- SOMEONE UP IN THE
GALLERY- AND WE'LL START. WITH
THE WITH MISS BURMA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS JUST LIKE TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR FOR ALL OF
THE ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL AND
THE PROGRESS THAT IS MADE. AND
THE KNOWLEDGE IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT SOME CHANGES THAT MAY BE
FORTHCOMING- RELATED TO LEAVE
TIME AND ADDRESSING THE SUNSET
AND CERTAINLY AN URGENCY CLAUSE
IF WE CAN. FIND A WAY FORWARD
HERE SO THAT WE CAN GET RELIEF
TO THESE WORKERS SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. SO WE'RE VERY FOR
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND ALSO FOR
THE- ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THE
5% AND FIVE WORKER. THRESHOLD
IS MAYBE NOT A WORKABLE
SOLUTION BUT PRECIADO
PERSPECTIVE OF TRYING TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND THE
GOVERNOR TO FIND A WORKABLE
PROTECTION FOR ALL WORKERS NOT
JUST MY MEMBERS OF FIREFIGHTERS
BUT ALL THOSE WHO ARE PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY TO
REPORT. TO WORK EVERY DAY SO
WHILE I'M- KIND OF IN BETWEEN
ON THE POSITION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO STEADFASTLY WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
SUPPORTING A MEASURE THAT
ENCOMPASSES ALL OF THESE
PROVISIONS WERE ALSO GRATEFUL
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER ON
THIS COMMITTEE WHO HAS. JOINED
YOU IN LEADING OF THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE AS A
BILL IN FRONT OF MR THE AUTHORS
COMMITTEE SOON SO WE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU MISS BURMA ARE THERE
OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. OTHER
WITNESSES. ANYONE ELSE IN LINE.
IF NOT WE'LL GO TO THE AT&T
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE ONE FIVE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ONE FIVE NINE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT THAT FLYING
FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MUCH TIGHTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
STOMACH WAS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
ALSO OURSELVES OF THE COMMENTS
OF THE AUTHOR AND JUST WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT ARE. WITH
CONCERNS POSITION THAT WE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
PRIMARILY REFLECTED THE- FIVE
AND FIVE LANGUAGE THAT IS BEING
REMOVED FROM THE BILL. AND SO
WITH THAT WHAT WE DO BELIEVE
WHAT'S LEFT IN THE BILL- COULD.
POTENTIALLY BE MADE STRONGER
AND COULD. COULD BE IMPROVED
AND IN VARIOUS WAYS THAT. VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OFFER AND
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR.
WORKING TOGETHER ON THE BALLOT
COUNTS LIKE- EVERYTHING IS
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND SO WE DON'T. AT THIS POINT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL BUT VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO REMAINING INVOLVED
HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
SOMETHING. THAT TAKES. TERRIBLE
WORKERS THANKS A LOT. THANK YOU
MISTER STEIGER AND THEN. THANK
YOU NEXT WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN LINE ONE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JANUARY CARROT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
AT ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO-
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE ONE FIVE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE ONE
FIVE NINE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME- ANYONE HERE IN THE
BUILDING. WISHING TO OPPOSE.
FROM ONE OF THOSE REMOTE. VIDEO
SITES ANYONE OPPOSING. IF NOT
WE'LL GO TO THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
AND ONCE AGAIN FOR ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO OPPOSE SB ONE ONE FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
IF YOU WANT TO OPPOSE IT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO WELL THE
TOTAL LINE THIRTY. THEY'RE
ABOUT JUST WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CALLED SPECIAL WITH
THE APPLICATION CALIFORNIA FOR
DEMONSTRATORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT LINE UP THIRTY SEVEN. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN DROPPED WE'LL GO
NEXT TO THE LINE ONE MOMENT
WELL NEXT LINE OF FIFTY THREE.
HI THIS IS AUDREY RETIRED CHECK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO NEXT TO THE LINE UP
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING OF
VICTORY HERE TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE AT THE PRODUCERS WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
WILL BE ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO NEXT TO LINE
UP TWENTY TWO. WELL GOOD
MORNING THIS IS EDWIN LOMBARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
OPPOSING THE BILL. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO NEXT STORYLINE THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING THIS BILL
VERMAELEN REPRESENTING
ACCLAMATION INSURANCE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND ALLIED
MANAGED CARE- LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THE BILL
BUT AT THIS POINT WE STILL HAVE
MAJOR CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO OUT NEXT TO LINE
FORTY TWO. A GOOD MORNING
ARMAND A FOURTH WITH THE VALUE
ADDITION COMES A CO CREATION
BICA IN OPPOSITION TO AT ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT LINE. TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS CONTRACTED OUT
TO CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT VERSION
OF MINE ARE COMMON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO NEXT TIME FORTY
SEVEN. GEN MERRIER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALSO ALIGNING OURSELVES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE COALITION FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OVER NEXT LINE EIGHTEEN. MY
MAINTAIN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY. AND
FORTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN. MOVEON
WHY SB. FIVE ZERO. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BRIAN LITTLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT DOOR IN THE FIFTEEN. THIS
IS ONE OF THE FOLLOWING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO ON
THE LINE FIFTY TWO. JOINT
COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE POINT FORTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JEAN HEARD HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WILL
GO ON TO THE LINE FORTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BY KAMALA
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
WINE GRAPE GROWERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE THIRTY NINE. HI
WITH PETER THIEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GERRY PASSED
MORE WITH THE CONGRESS IN
CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAXTED LINE FIFTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON ON
THE APPLE STATISTICIAN OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
TWENTY NINE. THE MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE RICE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IMPRENSA AT
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE AMENDMENTS TODAY AND ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE FORTY SIX. NUMBER
CAME WITH THE APPLICATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
ALTHOUGH I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AND WHEN I LIE ON A COMMENT CAL
PRETTY COLLECTION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING IS JOHN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS ASSOCIATION
AND CALIFORNIA POLLS
SPONSORSHIP ASIAN ZING OF THE
LIBERTY MUTUAL INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND WERE OPPOSED TO
THE EXTENSION OF COVERAGE
ANTICIPATED IN THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE SIXTEEN. YES THIS IS
ROBERT WALTER CONTROLLERS FROM
THE LACK NATIONAL LATINO
EVANGELICAL COALITION- YEAH I'M
A PUBLISHED TO THEM. FIFTY
NINE. THANK YOU OUR NEXT LINE
THIRTY SIX. LINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON
LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
BASKETBALL BE HAPPILY AFRICAN
AMERICAN FARMERS THE CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT SUGAR CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS IN GROWTH OF THE
ASIAN BAR WHAT THE COMMITMENT
DEALERS GROWER SHIPPERS
ASSOCIATION ESSENTIAL
CALIFORNIA MEET THE FARMER
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION UNITED
ADD WHAT YOU HAVE OR CULTURAL
PROCESSES ASSOCIATION WESTERN
PLANT HELP WITH THE. CREATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAX TWO LINE. FIFTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING YOUR MEMBERS ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PROERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE CONTACT INFO
SECTION THREE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEES WORK ON- WORKING ON
THIS BILL SO FAR. THANK YOU M.
LINE SIXTY ONE. YEAH HI
MICROBES AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION- IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA A COALITION
WORKERS COMPENSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
ANYONE WHO OPPOSES. S. B. ONE
ONE FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE THIRTY SIX
LINE IS OPEN. I AM THIRTY SIX
ALIVE AS OPEN PLEASE ADD ME TO
YOUR PHONE. MOVEON THERE IS NO
ONE FURTHER OPPOSING SB ONE ONE
FIVE NINE. TO THE MODERATORS
CARE ACT NEARLY. WHO WAS A- TO
THE MODERATOR WE HAVE AT THE
WITNESSES ON THE MAIN LINE TO
DO THE MAIN OPPOSITION THAT
JUST WERE CALLED ON. JERRY
BROWN THAT THE MAIN OPPOSITION
WHY. CAN WE GO AHEAD AND BE
RECOGNIZED THAT THAT WE HAVE TO
KEEP TRACK. AS WELL AS TCWC- TO
DO THAT THE MAIN OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. MISTER SMITH SO
YOU'RE LIVE ON THE LINE RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN MAKE YOUR TESTIMONY
YOU PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
SCHMELZER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- MY NAME J.
CONSULTOR VERY QUICKLY IN HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION. AND PRISON THE
PUBLIC RISK INTEGRATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT ALSO
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALCHAMBER OF CALIFORNIA JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES. IN THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO REALLY WANT
TO THINK THE AUTHORS- AND STAFF
FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
TIME THEY EXPECT TALKING TO ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS SINCE MARCH
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST. A CONVERSATION THAT WAS
REFERENCED EARLIER- WE REALLY
RESPECTFULLY WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BUT IT'S
WITH THE NEW ONES I THINK A LOT
OF A LOT LIKE SOME OF THE OTHER
FOLKS WHO SPOKE- WE'RE NOT
ASKING YOU TO VOTE AGAINST. THE
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE TODAY I WANNA
MAKE THAT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR- ARE
OPPOSITION THAT SPOKE WITH
FOCUSED MAINLY ON SECTION
THREE- IN TERMS OF SECTIONS ONE
INTO SECTION ONE- THE
CODIFICATION OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER- WE'RE TOTALLY FINE WITH
THAT. THAT SECTION TO THE
FORWARD FACING PRESUMPTION FOR
SOME POLICE FIRE AND HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. I HAD A LINE'S
PRETTY CLOSELY WITH WHAT WAS
DONE IN THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THERE'S A FEW ROUGH EDGES THAT
WE WOULD PROBABLY PREFER TO
WORK OUT BUT I THINK IF IT WERE
JUST SECTIONS ONE AND TWO.
PROCEEDING AT THIS POINT- MOST
OF THE OPPOSITION COALITION OF
MY CLIENTS I WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION AND MANY WOULD MOVE
INTO A SUPPORT POSITION- REALLY
QUICKLY THE SYSTEM IS. FORMING
ACTUALLY QUITE WELL BY WAY OF
REMINDER WE HAVE A NO FAULT
SYSTEM WHICH MEANS IT. DOESN'T
MATTER. WHO IS RESPOND FOR IN
FACT. HAPPENED AT WORK IT NEEDS
TO BE PICKED UP BY SYSTEM AND
WHAT WE HAVE IT DOES. TO THAT
AS LIBERAL. CLOSET I HEARD TALK
ABOUT. REFERENCE NOT OUR FAULT
THIS WEEK AND I JUST MEANS.
THAT WHEN A JUDGE THE VALUE THE
LAW THEY HAVE TO ERR ON THE
SIDE OF THE INJURED WORKER IN
PROVIDING BENEFITS TO THE
INJURED WORKER. TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE CLAIMS ARE
BEING ACCEPTED RIGHT NOW
THERE'S TWO MAJOR REASONS THAT
THEY'RE NOT I WANT TO TOUCH ON
THOSE BRIEFLY BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED. ONE
PEOPLE FILE CLAIMS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT SURE THEY'RE ACTUALLY SICK
THEY KILLED THOUGH THEY HAVE NO
EXPOSURE AND SO THEY NEED TO GO
AHEAD AND FILE A CLAIM. AS A
PROTECTIVE MEASURE UP
COMPLETELY REASONABLE- WHAT
HAPPENS A LOT OF THE CASE THAT
THEY NEVER GET SECOND I NEVER
CAST BECAUSE THE POCKET OF THE
CODE THAT. WE ARE REQUIRED BY
LAW AT THAT POINT TO ACT ON
THOSE CLAIMS EITHER ACCEPT OR
DENY THEM WITHIN THE STATUTORY
PERIOD. OF THOSE PLANS
ULTIMATELY DENIED. THE OTHER
MAJOR CATEGORY THAT WE'VE SEEN
SOMEWHERE- YOU KNOW NORTH OF
TEN PERCENT. IS IN THE ACTUAL
CLAIM FORM. THE INJURED WORKER
TOLD US THAT THEY DIDN'T GET IT
AT WORK. SO THEY WILL FILE A
CLAIM FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
ON THE CLAIM FORM THEY'LL SAY I
GOT PREVENT FROM. MY WIFE MY
SPOUSE MY CHILD WHATEVER IT
STATE THEY GIVE US A FACTUAL
BASIS. FOR IT NOT OCCURRING AT
WORK. I ON SECTION TWO. WHICH I
UNDER. IS THE BILL'S. WITH VERY
QUICKLY THIS CHAIR WE TWO MAJOR
CONCERN. WHY X. BROAD. 60% OF
THE- COLA. THAT THE- CLAIMS
COATED INFECTION ARE. INSIDE OF
THE CATEGORIES OF EMPLOYEES
COVERED BY SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL. SO WE JUST DON'T SEE A
NEED. TO CREATE A COMPLICATED.
TRIGGER ON TRIGGER OFF
MECHANISM THAT REQUIRES A BUNCH
OF DATA TRACKING- FOR DIRECT OF
THE EMPLOYEES WHERE. THE DATA
WOULD INDICATE THAT THERE IS
NOT A HIGH CONCENTRATION. OF
INFECTIONS OR A HIGH
CONCENTRATION OF RISK. THERE'S
ONE MAJOR ISSUE THAT I DO WANT
TO RAISE- ROLLED INTO THIS
CLUSTER. APPROACH THAT HAD
MAJOR CONCERNS MY NUMBER IS NOT
AS- IF WE HAVE TO SIMILARLY
SITUATED EMPLOYEES SAY THERE'S-
DAY DO THE SAME JOB THEY WORK
IN THE SAME LOCATION. BUT ONE
OF THEM BABY GOT SICK DURING
THE PERIOD. TRANSACTION THE ONE
DIDN'T MAYBE THE FACT FOR BOTH.
ARE NOT CLEAR. AS AN EMPLOYER
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PICK UP
ONE AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
TO PICK UP THE OTHER AND IT
PUTS US IN A SITUATION OF
TREATING VERY SIMILAR EMPLOYEES
VERY DEFINITELY. THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY PROBLEMATIC
FROM THE WORK. PERSPECTIVE SO
WITH THAT. WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
FOR THE MEASURE DESPITE THE
FACT. I'M OPPOSED TO IT- IT'S A
STRANGE POSITION AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. WE REALLY
PREPARED ALL. FIFTEEN DOT. WE.
TO REACH. AN OUTCOME WE CAN.
ALL BE PROUD OF AS WE BEFORE
THANK YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER SCHMIDT. IN I'VE WAS A
ONE OTHER PER IN. SORT OF
PRIMARY OPPONENT. MR CARE
CHECHNYA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IF I COULD SPEAK FOR A MINUTE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AB CAN MEET IF YOU
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT DURING THE
SHUTDOWN PAGE INTO PANDEMIC
THERE WAS A NEED TO ADDRESS THE
RISK ISN'T TO WORKERS. THAT
THEY WERE UNDERTAKING JUST BY
LEAVING THEIR HOMES- IN
INTERACTING WITH THE PUBLIC BUT
SINCE THEN THE LOCK DOWN THE
LARGELY BEEN LIFTED IN
WORKPLACES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT APPROPRIATE SAFETY
MEASURES SO WE NO LONGER SEE
THE NEED FOR A BROAD AND
EXPANSIVE PRESUMPTION EXCEPT
PERHAPS FOR THE MOST ESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE
UNSTRUCTURED CONTACT WITH THE
WITH THE PUBLIC ESPECIALLY
PRESUMPTION THAT EXTENDS OVER
THREE YEARS INTO THE FUTURE
GIVEN HOW DRASTICALLY OUR LIVES
CHANGED IN JUST A FEW MONTHS-
BUT THAT BEING SAID THAT THE
INTEREST. WILL BE THIRTY NINE
ARTICLE WAS BEEN TO WORK WITH
THE OFFICE ON THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL WOULD BE HEARD TODAY AND
THE EVENTUALLY CONTENT GOING TO
BROADEN THE BILL EVEN FURTHER
PLACES COUNTIES AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN JEOPARDY OF. NOT
CAUGHT TO OUR- OKAY. HELP FUND
WORKER PROGRAM. IF YOU WERE
STRESS AND IN COST FROM DIRECT
RESPONDING TO THE CORONA I WILL
GO IN ALL OF THAT I THINK THE
YOU GUYS KNOW MOST OF IT BUT
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS TAX THE
FUNDS. IT'S A FUNDS THE HELL
THANK YOU SERVICES AND PUBLIC
SIR THERE SO QUICK RIGHT NOW AS
AN ADDITIONAL THERE'S THE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEMS FUNCTIONS
A PRESUMPTION. THANK OF WORKERS
BEEN BY COHEN A- POLITICAL AND
AGENCIES ARE LARGELY APPROVING
THOSE CLAIMS WHEN THERE IS A
POSITIVE TEST. SO WE APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED WORK OF THE
AUTHORS ON SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
BUT WE UST REMAIN OPPOSED AT
THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
SIXTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I AM WORKING QUITE WILLIAM
PRESIDENT OF YOU GET A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND I'M SPEAKING IN
THE POLLS TO THE BILL AS IT IS
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. TO THE
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
UPON THE PEOPLE SEEKING TO
OPPOSE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NO OTHERS AT THIS
TIME GOOD WILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP. MADAME MODERATOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
VICE CHAIR MAY AS- YEAH I DON'T
KNOW FIVE THE QUESTION I JUST
HAVE A STATEMENT IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S OKAY I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS AT TODAY- IN REGARDS TO
SECTION TO. THIS COMMITTEE- AS
A MATTER OF LAW- IS VERY-
COMFORTABLE WITH THE REVIVAL
PRESUMPTION ASIF AS IT AFFECTS
OUR PEACE OFFICERS- AND
FIREFIGHTERS- AND IT MAKES A
PERFECT SENSE- IN IN REGARDS TO
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR THAT
CARE WORKERS MAKES PERFECT
SENSE AS WELL. I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SECTION THREE- AS
THE WAY THE FORMULA THAT WAS
PUT TOGETHER IN REGARDS TO ALL
EMPLOYEES THAT NOW COURSE HAS
BEEN AMENDED THERE'S INTENT
LANGUAGE THAT THAT'S THERE AND
BECAUSE OF MY AFFECTION FOR THE
AUTHOR- HAD MY AFFECTION FOR
THE CHAIR- AND STAFF I KNOW
THAT YOU GUYS WILL BE WORKING
DILIGENTLY- AS WE AS WE MOVE
THROUGH. THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SYSTEM WILL REMAIN SOUND AND
THE COSTA TO BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS I WILL NOT
BE- YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAS BUILT A
MOOSE WAS OF ON ON THE FLOOR
IT'LL. BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
THAT WE CAN BE SUPPORTIVE OF. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT SENATOR HILL
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR AFFECTION
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
FIREFIGHTERS OR POLICE OFFICERS
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE TO
DEAL WITH PEOPLE THEY'RE GOING
TO HOMES THEY'RE SUPPOSED DAY
IN AND DAY OUT AS FAR AS OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS GOAL OF MY
DAUGHTER'S IN THERE SHE'S A ARE
IN A HOSPITAL DOWN HERE A
COUPLE MILES AWAY AND PEOPLE
GET SICK THEY GO TO HOSPITALS
SO THEY SEE THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED DAY IN AND DAY OUT. IT
IS TOUGH IN REDUCING THE DEATH
AND WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS AND
TO ME IT'S A SMALL LAST TO MIX
WE PROTECT OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS WHO ARE VITAL AND-
RIGHT NOW THE CURVAS HOPEFULLY
FLATTENING BUT THOSE FOLKS
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE THEY HAVE
TO GO TO WORK THERE DEAL WITH
THE FORMAL SICK PEOPLE. SO FOR
THE- VOTING I. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER- COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
OTHER STATEMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. I'M A JOINT
AUTHORED TOO SO I GUESS I'M IN
THE SAME BOAT A MISTER COOLEY
HAS A STATEMENT OR QUESTION.
BECAUSE THIS IS TIED TO CLOVER
THIS IS ACTUALLY A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHICH IS INTENSE NOW. AND IN
GENERAL WE DO THINK A LITTLE
TALE ALL. BY SOME MEANS HERD
IMMUNITY VACCINE SO IT ACTUALLY
IS DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THE
OTHER ERRORS WHICH WE'VE
EXPANDED PRESUMPTIONS. OR
RESPECT FOR CONTINUITY OVER
TIME THE GENERAL AND SO THE FAX
SO I THINK FOR PEACE OF MIND TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO ARE.
FIGHTING THE BATTLE I THINK IT
IS APPROPRIATE. BUT  DO THINK
AS POLICY MAKERS IT'S WELL TO
NOTE THAT THIS IS A-
CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH OVER TIME.
WE DO ANTICIPATE WON'T BE WORSE
AND VERY LIKELY WILL BE
DIFFERENT THE WAY IT UNFOLDS AS
A PRESUMPTION. THANK YOU MR
COOLEY THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
POINT TO MAKE. MISCON LONGER
DID YOU. IT'S A ONCE AGAIN
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IN ECHO MANY
OF THE SENTIMENT SHARED BY MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS COMMITTEE I
WILL BE LAYING OFF THE- ON THE
VOTE TODAY BUT I LOOK FORWARD
TO VOTING FOR THIS ON THE FLOOR
WHEN IT REACHES US KNOWING THAT
THE AUTHOR IS GOING TO WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH THOSE WHO AM.
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN
SPECIFICALLY THOSE IN THE
GALLERY- ABOUT COMING TO SOME
CONSENSUS AROUND THE TIMING BUT
AS I MENTIONED I LOOK FORWARD
TO BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
ON THE FLOOR BECAUSE I KNOW THE
INTENT. OF THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS HIS COMMITMENT TO FINDING
THE PATH IS TRUE. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. STATEMENTS OR QUESTIONS-
I ERRED I MENTION THAT I'M A
JOINT AUTHOR I'M ACTUALLY
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR. SLIGHT
DISTINCTION BUT I DIDN'T WANT
TO MISSPEAK CENTER HELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO WRAP UP YOUR OF
PRESENTATION I'D BE HONORED TO
MISTER CHAIR AND AS THE
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR OF INDIA
AND I'M PROUD OF THAT FACT
BECAUSE I HAVE THAT SAME
AFFECTION FOR YOU. AS A MATTER
MAYES IT DOES IT LIKE TO- IT
REALLY IS AN HONOR TO PRESENT
THIS BILL TODAY AND I WANTED TO
JUST PICK YOU BACK UP SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT DOESN'T
REMEMBER COOPER MADE BECAUSE HE
HAS BEEN A LEADER. IN THIS
CHARGE IN THIS FIGHT AND ALSO
HAS A BILL IN THE SPACE THAT
WILL IS BEING HEARD TODAY AND-
THE COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE-
I'D LABOR COMMITTEE AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
IT RIGHT. YOU COULD THE
OPPOSITE WHICH- CONSIDERABLE
CAN EARN THAT WE HEARD WE'VE
GOT OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US
OVER THE NEXT TWO WEEKS BUT I
BELIEVE WE WILL GET THERE IN
FACT I KNOW WE HAVE TO GET
THERE BECAUSE THIS IS TO PORT
OF A ISSUE. ALL OF ALL. WITH
FIRST RESPONDER. WHETHER
CENTRAL WORK. EVERITT CIRCUIT
IT IS IF THEY AFFECTED BY VIRUS
WE WANT TO SURE THEY ARE PART
AND DATE THAT THEY ARE COVERED
AND THAT THEY WILL RECEIVE THE
CARE IN THE TREATMENT THAT THEY
DESERVE AND THAT WE ALL KNOW
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO AND SHOULD
BE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CONVERSATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. GOOD THERE
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND TO.
APPROVE THIS BILL WITH THE-
CHANGES THAT WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED
A COUPLE TIMES- THE DELETION OF
LANGUAGE AND THE ADDITION OF
THE INTENT LANGUAGE- ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS IF NOT LET'S
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DALY HI DALY AYE
MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN BERMAN
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO CALDERON
CALDERON AYE CHAN CHEN AYE
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
AYE FRAZIER GIPSON GIPSON
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I KAMLAGER.
VOEPEL. IT WOULD WHAT I. THREE
THIS TEND TO ONE THERE WERE TEN
AYE VOTES. ONE NO VOTE. IN A
COUPLE EXTENSIONS THANK YOU
RICHARD THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
RICHARD THANK YOU SENATOR WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON.
V. EIGHT- SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
DO PASSED AS AMENDED COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE FRAZIER. THE BILL
THERE ANY OTHER ANY OTHER ADD
ONS CONSENT CALENDAR. COOLEY
COOLEY AYE FRAZIER. THIRTEEN
ZERO. GREAT I THINK WE'VE GIVEN
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO ADD
ON. CORRECT AND THAT'S STELZER
STAFF IS VERIFYING THAT SO IN
THAT CASE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.